the Joe Rogan experience I lived up in
Alaska for a year and it was a whole
different world this is a different
world hold it well barely America yeah
it's like it's a really nice place to
visit
I love Anchorage
yeah I've been once but man I really
enjoy the [ __ ] out of it when did you go
up there um I guess this - three years
ago my friend Ari Shaffir and I we did
some salmon fishing then we do it did a
couple shows up there yeah yeah we had a
great time man yeah like during I think
like April to you know probably
September is really it's awesome it's
hard to sleep though yeah I mean because
you gotta cover your eyes like it's
weird yeah like you're tired and it
looks like it's two o'clock in the
afternoon like this is talking strange
that's pretty cool though yeah it
doesn't get too warm up there didn't
know obviously but those mosquitoes are
gangster they're like they should be
like the state bird
[Laughter]
they're terrible so big and so
aggressive they don't even make sense
yeah yeah we we got out of the car we
got to the river and you know you pull
up the trailhead and we we got out of
the car and we hadn't sprayed the bug
spray on we opened up the door I was
thinking well we'll get out you know
I'll put my clothes on then I'll spray
myself with bug spray the moment we
opened the door the car was filled with
a hundred mosquitoes like that how the
[ __ ] do they even know we're here
oh they just found us go ahead fresh
blood just open the door we're inside
we're spraying bug spray inside the
truck it's ridiculous it's so awesome
yeah it's a it's a crazy place to live
but it's also like when you're up there
you you recognize like oh like this is a
these people have a way closer
relationship with the natural world than
we do it gets cold as [ __ ] in the winter
they're surrounded by grizzly bears
moose are everywhere deer everywhere
it's just a different different
relationship with wildlife yeah it's
like you know and everything up there
like the one thing I noticed is if
whether you're going out - there was a
cabin there was a cabin at Mount Denali
and so what we would do is we'd ride
snow machines you have to park and then
you had to ride snow machines out to it
and it's like everything you do up there
is it's it's like serious you know I
mean it's not us like you better take it
serious or you could die yeah everything
everything everything every now yeah if
you want to go fishing or you know on
the river or whatever like it's all it's
all serious but it seems like the people
have a different at it what is this the
mosquitoes there almost swarm guys
that's in Alaska yeah they can kill baby
caribou caribou calves literally
mosquitoes will like sting them around
their eyeballs they're [ __ ] until
they died swarm engulf scientists
recorded god-awful phenomenon that's
great man that's that's nature right
that's what happens when you only get to
live for a couple months
yeah you just gotta go all out yeah
that's why in LA there's [ __ ] zero
mosquitoes like they're just like chill
oh my God look at these legs are just
covered they'll bite you right through
your [ __ ] pants don't give a [ __ ]
about your pants look at that guy's foot
oh my god look it click on the foot
covered in mosquitoes
that is crazy that is crazy
oh my god that gives me the
heebie-jeebies just looking at it why is
that guy letting that happen back
package with monster skeeters yeah
they're doing it for the ground getting
your feet lit up just for Instagram it's
not worth it terrible
keep your feet protected bro it's too
crazy they'll go right through your
socks anything terribly I don't give a
[ __ ] about clothes or clothes you're not
gonna protect you clothes
nope not up there
[Applause]